hi there reject nation Greg Alba John
Humphrey we watch the far from home us
trailer just now we're uploading this
much later I wanted to give that time to
perform algorithms and all that and also
if you haven't seen it there is a little
intro sketch it's only about a minute
long won't take up most of the video
don't worry but uh yeah a lot of people
seem to be laughing at it so yay
we're gonna watch the International
trailer a lot of people a lot of the
comments were like before we hop into
this I wanted to say a special thank you
to each and every one of you who has
been downloading and following us on
this Stardust app there's a lot of
youtubers on there a lot of big time
personalities we post regularly over
their 30 second reaction reviews for any
film TV show or trailer you guys should
download the app follow us today it's
all free to use Costco samples that's
the chicken different music yeah
[Music]
Parker's 11
[Laughter]
[Music]
although I couldn't sense that for us
somebody point on the comments that it's
because Nick Fury is not a threat which
[Music]
are you going to step up
Wow
[Music]
I hope that joke is really an ongoing
joke throughout yeah
every time we cut to that carrot Flash
Thompson loves spider-man he's got like
spider-man underoos on or so they said
in the comments that people were saying
that because Nick Fury is not a threat
that's why - incensed um yeah I don't
know exactly what the inner workings of
the spider sense is you know cuz I'm
like you know dude with a tranquilizer
gun could theoretically be a threat
either way but at the same time maybe
the subconscious you know the spider
sense knows to factor Nick Fury out of
life I would like Ned falling over and
everything maybe the mo might play a
little bit different where he does get
shot and then it supposed to be like
danger and then wait Nick Fury or maybe
yeah maybe he's just so good at avoiding
the spider sense by now when that
opening of when they're at the airport
and this suits revealed yeah my first
reaction was like oh no whoa but then
you know it's just a costume after scene
into the spider verse which I'm assuming
is somewhat connected in some way call
from Sony this is just an alternate
universe of that yeah I feel like
spider-verse leaves the door open anyway
well I'm have in terms of how remember
how early on in that movie a lot of
people were buying spider-man costumes
and yeah and then this well people have
I got a mentioned I spaced off the
real-life hero yeah exactly so by now at
this point in the story you know it's
got to be less weird to see a spider-man
costume just out and around yeah it's a
really expensive Toys R Us cost you
cosplayers yourself really fancy hear it
I like to find me the first half of this
is really what's different but I like
the vibe having
one of these Marvel movies like take
place not in a fantastical realm or
across the universe but just in Europe
well this just seems like danger follows
him wherever he goes in some way no
matter how far from home I got the point
of the cycle yeah you know the first one
came home and there was also a
homecoming dance double title I was on
the campus show and he was talking about
how he wasn't hearing the theory that
Avengers infinity war picks up right
after this
that's when they're on the school bus
hmm and then all gets off but it can't
be a private good point where he was
like that's a very long bus trip
[Laughter]
the buzz across the Atlantic we flew
there which we have a waterproof bus
it's a submarine yeah I mean yes they
could be on a bus back from JFK or
something but this is not as fun all
right that was a case I just feel really
bad for Peter yeah I would I remember in
the first one of homecoming it wasn't
zendaya who he was into and now it seems
like they're really building on this
romance this time around somebody didn't
even touch on the other trailer so was
that element yeah I don't know it's just
a good thing that I was like yeah we all
expected that so I didn't really hear
about it but I'm wondering if the
chemistry here is like yeah it's a cute
little moment therefore I have value no
no that's not what I meant
unless it I feel self-aware joke right
there and who claim not to hate women
but a feminism I feel like that joke has
just come further into the full circle
where it's like oh god this is a
feminism moment she's like I'm just
messing with you guys
chill out it's I I did not read into it
like that in the slightest
yeah when I saw their comments I was
like what are they talking about
but back I'm like that's what everyone's
said over something you know that joke
it's just a cute little banter of
teenagers of her making Peter
uncomfortable
yeah and it's totally in line with any
of the things she would have said in the
first movie said about it I don't know
go back for the context either way I
really hope that their chemistry really
shines in this one especially if they're
building and teasing hinting at a
romance with the new MJ the Michelle
Jones yeah oh I remember what it was
people in the comments were there
onething oh snap image there I did I did
and speaking of the Thanos snap image
that I just threw in there
what you don't like that fourth wall
break people were theorizing in the
comments that the moment we're happy
says to spider-man that you know we're
alone now you're all alone it is an
allusion to perhaps the fate of Tony
Stark because this is also a pretty
stark 'lest trailer both of these
trailers people are wondering if maybe
happy means we are alone as in free of
Tony Stark now like Rare is the day when
we like over dissected trailer generally
speaking for someone comes down it goes
discover all your Christmas presents
ahead of time and then Christmas calm
you're like yep I think the thing that
will probably offer the biggest surprise
here is the fact that there will be
actual surprises in this movie yeah as
weird as the stupid of a sentence as
that sounds like the first one played it
relatively safe other than it's cool
Adrian Toomes being the father reveal at
the end there's a pretty safe movie and
it's good getting things back on track
movie yeah and for it I get the
impression we're gonna get some
surprises I'm under the impression that
there's something Mysterio's doing with
allusions in some way like maybe the
elementals are real maybe it's kind of
hard for me to believe it
yeah yeah I feel like that might be a
little bit annoying making these big old
trips around town and yeah by now all
this adventure and stakes was pointless
that'd be kind of a frustrating film but
hey what a villainous scheme to just
waste everyone's property trickery it's
smoke and mirrors this was a cool
trailer I prefer the other one yeah
it'll set new trailer I was like oh damn
the way they hyped it yeah I like this
trailer on top of the other one because
in this one I'm like ooh slightly more
of the Europe mood that this movie's
gonna have this trailer is paced
differently it's paced better and it's
more concise Peter it wants to just go
on a school trip get away from being
spider-man because the other trailer is
kind of like he's doing charity work or
something and then over good it's like
you're a bad man man oh yeah the other
trailer feels like okay here's a bunch
of cool stuff that's gonna be going on
spider-man yeah yeah and then this one
feels a little bit like here's kind of
what the movie will probably yeah this
is the set up he wants to go away and go
on this field trip bond with MJ have a
good time and then Nick Fury shows up
and it kind of just yeah so I feel like
this is a good concise trailer but yeah
it was cool listen guys before we wrap
this up I want to give a patron today
shout out to a man named bro and Max and
broen is a guy who has been off and on
on our patreon page but now he's back
he's on handsome man from Australia
really talented ambitious homeboy go
back to school like the way you want to
buddy
he had to deal with some setbacks had
got hacked into some of his accounts for
music that's bad putting this all out
there for you but I just want to put it
all out there but you know what I wanted
to tell you I want you to be like Peter
Parker and never give up just keep on
keepin on buddy I know that sometimes
life can be difficult and you and I have
been talking a lot you said you started
eating healthier December's sort of
working out really happy that you're
getting a fast-track on that so just
keep at it man we talked a lot about
improving our
mental health and everything and it's
cool to know that someone our side of
the world relates with me in those areas
it's universal language I love you man
you stay safe and be happy or you don't
try to be and if you're sad it's okay
just you know too much advice is
sometimes bad subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell down
a falls in the start us at people